guess what we're talking about in this video. race.
if it makes you uncomfortable to talk about race,
I encourage you to stick around
and watch the whole video
just to challenge your mindset
in the way that you think.
but if you're stuck in your ways,
keep scrolling.
I don't need no negativity.
I won't have to block nobody.
shout out to Emily Sears asking this question.
this question is so beautiful,
and it made me so happy when I read it.
she actually posted this in a few parts,
so I'm gonna read you the first part,
and then we'll walk through this part right here.
she said, I am interested in going into leadership
while continuing to nurture a diverse culture.
then she said,
as a white woman,
what are some things I can be aware of specifically
that ensures I am empowering my team
and making everyone feel motivated? beautiful.
I wanna go on record by saying
I don't speak for all black folks
or all people of color.
this is my opinion.
so take what you want and leave what you don't.
if you are a white woman or a white person
and you want to figure out how to empower
and motivate people of color,
understanding starts with your intention.
we feel when you ain't right.
we can feel when you are not right.
listen to me.
you're gonna have to do the work
and really evaluate yourself to get rid of the biases.
and the stereotypes that you have in your mind,
because when that is deeply rooted within you.
I'm not saying you're a bad person.
everybody's not a bad person.
some of us. it's our upbringing.
right? but you have to evaluate yourself
and get to the core of what your heart posture is.
and really check your intentions
and make sure you have good intentions.
next is understand that everyone's experience
in the workplace
is not the same.
a lot of times,
people of color are dealing with
being overlooked and undervalued,
microaggressions,
being spoken to in a condescending tone,
being painted as angry or combative
when they're simply having an opinion,
being excluded from projects
or excluded from a conversation.
this may not be your experience,
so acknowledge and empathize with the fact
that everyone's experience
is completely different.
next is look for opportunities to be inclusive.
if you're in a team meeting,
and everybody is white
except one Asian lady and one black male,
and those 2 minorities are being excluded
from the conversation,
they're being cut off
and intentionally excluded.
why don't you look over and say,
hey, Michelle,
what do you think?
or hey, Justin,
that's an opportunity to include them.
you're aware,
and you are including them in the conversation.
so, again, look for opportunities to be inclusive.
I actually have 4 more points,
so I'm gonna have to make this a part 2.
so come on back.